well you really did Oh Audrey an apology
for what you put her through the entire
kingdom of auradon loves you but we have
to ask did you pull the wool over
everyone's eyes there's a lot of
evidence that says you did was all of
this just a scheme to rule over auradon
we have our suspicions if you want to be
a good queen you're going to have to
admit to a few things first you know
what I actually thought you were brave
you're nothing but a chicken now it's a
villain kid turned Queen that everyone
loves but did she come buy that crown
honestly we've got a few red flags we
need to talk about concerning the new
queen of auradon
watch until the end to find out why mal
was the villain all along in descendents
3 before we get started we have to say
that we love mal from her purple hair to
her cool villain parent roots her sassy
but fun attitude mal is super awesome
she is totally bewitched us with her
charisma her beauty and her powers and
we're not the only ones Ben is
hopelessly in love with her she is
admired by all of the subjects of war
Don it seems like they don't even care
when she breaks the rules that everyone
else has to follow this will lead to the
demise of war Don will explain it all at
the end of this video a nefarious plan
first let's talk about how mal was able
to snatch the crown for herself in the
first movie she was loyal to her mother
Maleficent her task was to deceive the
people of auradon including Ben and
fairy godmother in hopes of stealing
fairy godmothers wand why to eliminate
the barrier around the Isle but things
didn't work out very well for Maleficent
and
here's why now versus Maleficent if now
had taken down the barrier in the first
movie she would still be under the
control of her mother Mao's mother has a
powerful hold over mal even when she
can't use magic remember the beginning
of d1 when mal tried to have a staredown
contest with her mom and wound up losing
mal didn't want that to happen again so
she came up with a different plan one
that didn't include her mother poor
Maleficent was turned into a lizard
while now got to rise to royalty in
auradon and that's not all Mao's rebel
magic mal has been breaking the rules
ever since the first descendants movie
she knew that magic was forbidden in
auradon but used it anyway she cast a
love spell on Ben stealing him away from
Audrey and she didn't do it for a love
she did it for power in descendants -
mal used her spell book to manipulate
Ben and trick the people of auradon but
when Ouma did the same thing and cast a
love spell on Ben everyone was appalled
so why the double standard we think mal
has been tricking the people of Ward on
since the very beginning they're
helpless against her powers of
persuasion Audrey now had it out for
Audrey since the very first time they
met sure Audrey seemed awkward around
now but can you blame her
Mouse mother put Audrey's mother in an
eternal coma and mal didn't even seem
sorry about it Mao stole Audrey's
boyfriend and she didn't even win him
over fair and square she put a spell on
him and why did she choose Ben because
he was next in line for the throne
Audrey didn't stand a chance against
Mouse powers of persuasion and things
only got worse for Audrey in descendant
3 turning a princess into a villain
Audrey fell right into mousetrap when
she became the queen of means with the
scepter in Audrey's heartbroken hands
she created chaos and destruction
throughout word on that took the focus
off of mal and her evil schemes mal has
only ever had one goal but we'll get to
that a little later
Audrey played right into mouth clam when
she cast the sleep spell on auradon
when she started turning people into
stone it was the perfect recipe for Mao
to get her way now turned Audrey into a
fake villain so everyone would focus on
her meanwhile the real villain had
diabolical plans for total domination
liar liar pants on fire
now couldn't even be honest with her
original VK friends I have to tell you
guys something she lied to those closest
to her so what's to stop her from lying
to everyone else when mal acted
concerned about letting criminals into
auradon
she made a rash decision to stop letting
innocent BK's into the kingdom I think
that we have to close barrier forever
but she kept it from her best friends it
wasn't until she was afraid everyone
would find out the truth that she
finally came clean right before they
turned to stone but maybe this was part
of her plan all along
power-hungry why was Mao so competitive
with who Matt there she was trying to
help save auradon and now is still power
grabbing Evie was so annoyed with it and
we can see why Mao had everything while
uma had nothing yet now still couldn't
share the leadership responsibilities
with uma that's because of mouse
insatiable hunger for power and that
brings us to mouths final plan for total
domination
while only rule ordered on when you
could rule everyone on the Isle to Mouse
original plan from the first descendants
movie finally worked in descendants
three she broke down the barrier which
is what she aimed to do all along and
now she's the ruler of everyone
including the villains of the Isle
very clever mal do you guys think mal is
the true villain in descendants three
tell us what your theories are in the
comments thanks for watching the things
be sure to subscribe to be the first to
see our latest videos and click that
thumbs up button while you're at it see
you next time
[Music]